- Sup y'all, this is Jay Park.
I'm gonna teach you how to drink soju.
Soju is the traditional drink of Korea.
Everybody drinks it.
You can drink it with your buddies
or you can drink it with
someone that's older than you.
It kinda fits for any occasion.
So what you do before you open the bottle
is you whip it around, turn it around,
hit it with your elbow for the sound
or for the looks.
And then you would crack it open.
And what some people do
is they hit it like that
just so all the stuff on the top
and all the bad stuff comes out.
And what you could do with the cap
is some people like to
play a game with it.
So you twist it around like this
and then you take turns flicking it.
Whoever flicks off this
little tail right here,
they have to drink the soju.
If you're pouring for someone
that's elder than you,
you wanna pour it with
two hands to show respect.
Just like this.
If it's your friend, just one hand.
Because you're comfortable, close.
Same thing when you're receiving it.
If it's someone elder, two hands.
Thank you.
If it's your friend,
just one hand like this.
And if it's someone elder, when you drink,
you wanna drink
with your back turned so that
they don't see you drink.
It's a sign of respect.
So this is how you cheers.
Gun-beh.
I just taught you how to drink soju.
It's Jay Park, only asian to
be signed under Roc Nation.
You're gonna see much more on me, alright.
Let's get it.